what has Kimo Walker been up to lately
the four-time All-Star and Fan Favorite
only played nine games with the Mavs
last season and hasn't touched the court
since or has he Kima recently took his
talents to the Euro league signing with
as Monaco but what Kima didn't know is
that playing overseas would give him a
stunning realization that basketball is
bigger than the NBA after bouncing
around from the Celtics Knicks and Mavs
recently Kima met with a couple of
friends who have Euroleague experience
that persuaded him to take the
opportunity because of the level of
competition he face as Monaco is one of
the top squads in Euro league and Kima
is making great money playing for them
going from an NBA Allstar to out of the
league and a short amount of time would
be a humbling experience to anyone but
it's great to see Kima keep going after
the injuries benching and buyouts to
remind the world that he still got game